I think there's pros and cons to
everybody that's going to be the same
for everything it's nice for women
because women can have more sex without
necessarily getting pregnant and having
kids women have a little bit more
Independence so they can explore
sexually without being tied down to one
man that they have to marry for men
there is more availability of sex I know
there was that 140 number but I think
that was quoted I want to say in 2021 it
was like when the pandemic was crazy and
everything I think that fell I don't
know what it fell to
um but I mean like yeah like sex is more
available now than it was in the past
for most people which is but there's
pros and cons right there's going to be
more competition for sex there's going
to be more competition for relationships
back 30 40 50 years ago all a man had to
do was work a job and he was basically
like guaranteed a wife because women
couldn't work
um yeah I think it's important to
recognize our pros and cons to
everything